that gives you a look at the stories in
star field but ultimately it's not our
story it's the story you create by who
you are and the choices you make and
that starts with character creation
[Music]
it's our most flexible yet
you can customize all the elements of
how you look
[Music]
you'll pick a background that gives you
three starting skills
[Music]
says here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful
there are optional traits and these come
with unique advantages and disadvantages
but it's not just in how you can look
and how your character plays and
develops
[Music]
the skill system combines the best from
our previous games
and you can unlock new skills as you
level up and then you rank those skills
up by using them and completing
challenges
and there's deep crafting systems from
running research projects with the
resources you find
to crafting weapon mods needed to
survive
[Music]
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation
you can choose where and how to build
each one
and you can hire characters you meet to
keep it up and running
but
that's not all
[Music]
you can even build your own spaceships
[Music]
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
i have to say it's so cool we just
absolutely love this
[Music]